Hey youtubers it's Charlie so everybody
was asking me to do a shazam Black Adam
video it's still going to be one of the
big justice league films Warner Brothers
confirmed in the last day that they are
still working on it
the rock is still attached to be Black
Adam this is to break down what's going
on with that will they announced that it
is connected to the larger DC Universe
if you guys didn't know that before I
mean you kinda have to assume that all
DC movies that are being made now are
inside this DC Universe but some of them
will be more connected than the others
like think of the core Justice League
members that we've already met those
films were incredibly closely linked
even suicide squad but thus far Suicide
Squad has been the only introduction to
magic in the DC Universe and it's very
supernatural kind of magic but they've
been using the blanket term for anybody
with any kind of powers no matter where
they got their powers no matter how they
work they've been calling them all
metahumans so even though it sounds kind
of weird they do call Superman a
metahuman in Suicide Squad so Billy
Batson who becomes shazam, black adam, anybody
from that area the comics would also be
considered a metahuman according to
amanda waller and the government but a
lot of you might remember a couple years
ago when they were just like getting
things rolling with batman vs superman
they announced that they signed the rock
as Black Adam in the shazam movie and
they'd begun development so cut to a
couple years later and it's like okay so
it's been a couple years but we haven't
heard anything is the movie dead what's happening
they said they're still developing it
with the rock but they haven't really
announced to release date
let's say that it's more real the movie
is more real than the Marvel Inhumans
movie because Kevin foggy took it off
the Marvel schedule but he's like we're
still working on it it's still happening
but it's not on the schedule so it's
like well how much is it happening? so
you have to take it with a grain of salt
so inhuman movie at Marvel is happening
Shazam movie is happening at DC just to
be determined in terms of release date
and they have not casted their Billy
Batson yet that's the next most
important thing because I think a lot of
people don't realize there's really like
three important characters that they
need to cast for the movie and they've
already cast Black Adam he's one he's
the big villain he'll be a lot of fun
he very much looks the part but they
need to cast the young Billy Batson
who's like a ten-year-old kid then they
need to cast his adult self who
will be the one walking around as shazam
when Billy Batson says his power word so
it sounds like they're looking for the
right story and then waiting for the
right kid to come along so just consider
it the same way you would consider the
Booster Gold movie there's a booster
gold movie that they're making it will
be part of the DC Universe but it's it's
kind of like a comedy type film so it's
not a perfect fit with the other movies
that they made so far but it's scheduled
for $MONTH 2018 release date that might
get pushed a little bit depending on how
development continues but there's a
person who is working on the script in
fact the person that is writing the
Booster Gold movie is actually one of
the writers for the flash TV show who is
developing it with greg berlanti so
that's a whole other thing if you have
absolutely no idea who the shazam
character is he's Billy Batson and this
is where it gets a lot of fun they could
have a lot of fun with the way they
weave the character in with the Justice
League in the future so Billy Batson
stumbles upon the wizard Shazam the rock
of eternity who is kind of like the
guardian of all magic on earth so he
imbues Billy Batson with this power to
do good so he has the ability to call
down the power of a bunch of different
gods you know kind of based on the Greek
pantheon
so like he has the speed of hermes so he
can be as fast as the flash he has
magical lightning like Zeus he can fly
he has a number of different powers that
he can use each at any given time but he
has to like specifically called down
those powers but they're activated when
he says his power word the word is
shazam so he says shazam and boom struck by the
magical lightning and what it does is it
transforms him into his ideal self and
his ideal self is an adult so when he's
walking around as shazam he looks like he
would if he were an adult but he's like
a ten-year-old kid walking around in the
body of his adult self so the fun part
is is that his adult self looks very
similar to Clark kent/superman so I
think it'd be really fun for the movie
to play with the idea that Superman is
like the god of Earth everybody either
worships him or hate him and thinks he's
a demon so Billy Batson ten-year-old kid
like a typical ten-year-old kid would
probably idealizes Superman in wants to
be like him so when he activates the
power of shazam wouldn't it be awesome
if he looked a little bit like Superman
in the movie now obviously they can't
have Henry
travel places and you can't make the
metaphor that literal but it can be
someone who looks relatively like Henry
Cavill so it's like oh of course a
ten-year-old kid in this universe would
probably love the idea of Superman and
think that he's the best thing ever when
your ideal self look kind of like
Superman so let me know in the comments
how do you think they're going to
connect the shazam movie to the Justice
League movie because they've already
done supernatural things because of
suicide squad so it's not super hard to
connect them but there has to be a
reason for billy batson to work with the
Justice League so that means that the
rock Black Adam in the movie will have
to do something that's so big and
terrible that it will get the attention
of Batman and the Justice League like oh
my god what is happening in this part of
the world there's this giant magical
battle ag Batman will have to see
Billy Batson as shazam take black adam
down and be like okay
he was also inspired by Superman
sacrifice so we should probably get him
on our team before something terrible
happens to him because remember Amanda
Waller's comment during Suicide Squad
she said we need to get these metahumans
on our team before somebody else picks
them up as if the other governments of
the world like the not-so-nice
governments of the world and other evil
organizations are trying to build their
own teams of metahumans so I think what
will happen is that you know whatever
goes that whatever the plot they want to
use for this shazams movies going to
be it'll just get the attention of the
Justice League I think Superman would
actually be a good cameo on that film
too you have Batman cameo and some of the
other films Superman should cameo and
some of the other films too but i think
he works better in films of more
powerful people like he would work
really well in the Aquaman movie, Shazaam
is another one too because shazam is kind
of like the Superman of magic any kind
of looks like him too in the comics so
let me know
do you think that the shazam actor like
the person as the adults shazam should
look kind of like Henry Cavill's version
of superman so hopefully they'll have a
little bit of fun with that but if there
was any confusion shazam movie still
happening will totally connect to
justice League but as announced in my
Aquaman video that i just posted i was
going to do Supergirl video but there's
a new round of the giveaway that starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video is just a twenty-dollar amazon
gift card so next video will be that
Supergirl season 2 video and then I'll
probably do some marvel after that
it's been a little while since I've
done a Marvel videos. While you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
my Aquaman video you can click here to
learn all about Superman and Supergirl
season 2 thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight